MALE SPEAKER: Hi everyone.
I'm here with Francois again.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: Hello.
MALE SPEAKER: Hi.
We're here to talk
about something related
to the previous talk we did
on channels, but different.
What is the difference
between Google Chrome,
the browser everybody
knows and uses, most of you
probably use it, and Chromium?
Chromium, I think
the first thing
we should say about it is that
it's an open source project.
That's really what
it's meant to be.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: Yeah.
The open source
project Chromium is
composed of three main things.
First is the browser, like you
said, the Chromium browser.
Then you have the
rendering engine, Blink,
was a fork of WebKit.
And finally you get the
operating system, Chromium OS.
MALE SPEAKER: So let's focus
on the browser side of things.
So let's set aside
the rendering engine
and the OS side of things.
So there's the Chromium browser,
and there's the Google Chrome
product which is also a browser.
Let's focus on the differences.
The first one,
probably an obvious one
to most people in terms of
difference, is the logo.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Different logos.
Different colors.
Googley colors for the Google
product, Google Chrome.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: We get
the blue one for Chromium,
and we get the yellow
one for Chrome Canary.
MALE SPEAKER: So Canary,
I think it's worth
mentioning, but maybe not
at this point just yet.
So first difference, logo.
Number one.
Number two, Chromium is
an open source project,
so the source code is
open source, and yet
at the same time
the product that we
ship, which is Google
branded, Google Chrome,
itself has a number
of pieces that
are not open source, because
we've licensed technology.
Another difference would be
that there is the bare bones
Chromium version,
and then there's
is the Chrome, which is not
open source because well--
which contains not
open source bits.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: So
that has consequences
on some of the features
that these browsers
are able to offer.
So for example, Chromium
will lack a number of things
because we're missing
those binary pieces we
have in the product.
Do you want to talk about those?
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: So
before mentioning that,
just two things that
people will understand.
So there are Chromium
builds that are available
on
download-chromium.appspot.com.
So basically, every day you
get several builds of Chromium
you can download and test.
And then you have the
Chromium browser package
that is maintained by
distribution maintainers.
So you get one for
[INAUDIBLE] for [INAUDIBLE]
for all the Linux dispersion.
You will see there
are some differences.
First, like you said,
licensing stuff.
You don't have Adobe Flash
embedded in Chromium.
MALE SPEAKER: So no Adobe Flash.
No Adobe PDF either?
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT:
No Adobe PDF either.
Yeah.
It's a plug in.
Basically the Chrome
team worked with Adobe
to provide the best security
experience for users.
That's in Google Chrome.
That's not in Chromium.
What else?
MALE SPEAKER: Codecs.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT:
Codecs obviously.
MALE SPEAKER: Codecs.
Audio and video codecs.
So Chromium, obviously I'm
sure, will support things like--
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: VP8,
VPN9, Opus, [INAUDIBLE],
all these different
source and great codecs
are available in Chromium.
But there are some
other great codecs
that you have to pay for.
And Google does it, and they
provide it in Google Chrome.
So this is MP3, H264,
and AC, I believe.
So if you don't know the
raw build of Chromium,
you don't have access
to those codecs.
But if you--
MALE SPEAKER: If
you access Chromium
through one of the
Linux distributions,
maybe the maintainer
of that distribution
has done the equivalent
work of Google
to fill some of those gaps.
Maybe not all.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT:
Not all, but some did.
So it's cool.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
So flash, PDF, codecs,
some differences here.
Maybe another major difference
we should mention at this point
is the update mechanism for the
bits that you have installed.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: And that's--
if you need to remember one
thing, that's the thing.
Google Chrome updates
whenever it needs.
The push updates you, as
a user, to protect you.
If you use Chromium, you rely
on the maintainer on yourself.
There is a huge level of-- like
there's a huge gap of security
here.
MALE SPEAKER: So
that's interesting.
Maybe at this time we
should mention Canary.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: Yeah.
So Chrome updates every
six weeks, roughly,
for a stable version.
Then you get Chromium.
You can download a Chromium
build everyday if you want.
MALE SPEAKER: Like
you do probably.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: Yeah.
Like I do.
But maybe you don't
want to do that.
You don't want to write
a base script for it.
You can just use Canary.
And Canary is basically Google
Chrome updated every day.
And this is where you should
test all the upcoming dev
tools feature for instance.
Or even just a Chrome feature.
MALE SPEAKER: So if
you're a developer,
typically you want to make sure
it works on the target, which
is Google Chrome,
which everybody uses.
But you probably want to test
on Canary as well, or maybe even
on Chromium to see what's coming
down the line if there are
new features you rely on that
are being added or changed.
That's probably a good thing
to do, to test on those things.
And they can all be installed
in the same machine, right?
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: So
one thing, at this time
Chrome Canary is not available
in Linux, just Windows and Mac.
MALE SPEAKER: So
Windows and Mac.
That's probably
worth mentioning.
One last big difference I
see is the syncing part,
which is something where it
relies on the Google identity
you can have in Google Chrome.
So that means you have access
to a number of synchronization
features, the
profile, all of that
is actually related
to the fact that you
can talk to Google services.
And that, obviously, is part
of the Google product, not
the open source project.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: So yeah,
but if you use some builds
maintained by a Linux
dispersion, some embed API key,
and you can do that.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
So that's the beauty of having
this open source project.
People can add value.
Google obviously
does its own product,
but others can do similar
things, or different things,
and innovate in different
ways and add their own value
on top of that.
Cool.
So I think we've gone through
a number of differences.
I hope it's more
clear for you than it
was before you
started watching this.
Thanks for watching.
I know it's clearer
for me before I
started talking to Francois.
Thanks for watching.
Cheers.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: See you guys.